what I want to do in this video is
explain what parallax what parallax
actually is and then try to visualize
what the parallax would be like in the
context of observing relatively nearby
stars and then in the next video we're
going to think about how we can use the
parallax of nearby stars to figure out
how far they actually are away from us
so parallax really is just the apparent
change in position of something based on
a different line of sight so when you
see that if you just look at if you just
while you're looking at out of the car
you're going to see that depending on
how far different things are from you it
looks like they're moving relative to
each other right now I'm looking at my
computer monitor and if I move my head
around or shake my head around it looks
like the wall behind the computer
monitor is moving relative to the
computer monitor we've all experienced
this but let's think about what parallax
means when looking at stars so let me
draw let me draw the Sun here and
obviously none of this is drawn to scale
so let me draw the Sun here and let me
draw the earth at some point in its
orbit around the Sun and we're going to
pretend like we're looking from above
the solar system so the earth will be
rotating the earth will be rotating in
this direction right over here and let's
say the star that we care about the star
that we care about is right over here
the star that we care about is right
over here
obviously not clearly not draw on the
scale and what we're going to do is
we're going to wait to the point in the
year so the point in our orbit around
the Earth so that right at dawn so we're
sitting right here on the surface of the
earth and just to simplify things we're
on the equator and let's say that this
is the Stars roughly in the plane of our
solar system so we're sitting right here
we're sitting right here on the equator
and then right at dawn right when the
first light of the Sun right when the
first light of the Sun begins to reach
me remember right now the Sun is
lighting up this side of the earth so
right when the first light of the Sun is
reaching me I'm looking I'm looking
straight up so if I look straight up
right when the first light of the Sun is
reaching me and I look straight
up I look straight up like that I will
be looking in that direction now so
let's say that that direction that I'm
looking at is this direction right over
here so let's say this and then let me
make it clear this is a separate part of
the diagram here this isn't the diagram
of the maybe I should do it maybe I'll
do it over here so if I'm looking at if
the night sky looks like this the night
sky looks like this the Sun is just
beginning to rise on the horizon if I
look straight up if I look straight up
I'm looking in this direction so where
would this star be relative to straight
up well straight ups going to be like
that the Sun is right if the Sun is
right the way I drew it right here right
to my left straight up is just like that
the Sun is just coming over the horizon
this star right here the apparent
position of this star relative to
straight up is going to be at some angle
at some angle to the left of straight up
it's going to be right over there and
obviously the star won't be that big
relative to your entire field of vision
but you get the idea maybe I'll draw it
a little bit smaller than light by just
like that so there's going to be some
angle here and this angle whatever it is
I don't know let's just call it let's
just call it theta that's going to be
the same angle as this and when I talk
about the angle I'm talking about if you
measure from a one side of the horizon
to the other side of the horizon you're
essentially looking around halfway
around the earth that would be 180
degrees so you could literally measure
what this angle is right over here
now let's say we waited six months six
months what's going to happen six months
we're going to be on this side of the
Sun our distance we're assuming that our
distance is relatively constant at one
astronomical unit now what happens if we
wait remember the Sun the earth is
rotating the earth is rotating like this
so if we wait right at sunset right when
the last glimpse of the Sun has just
gone away because you can remember right
now right now the Sun is illuminating
this side of the earth the Sun is going
to be illuminating that's how the earth
so if we're sitting right at the equator
right over there right when the Sun is
just setting we look straight up
right when the Sun is just setting we
look straight up let me do that in the
same color we look the straight up so
six months later when we look straight
up where is the star relative to
straight up
well now the star will be to the right
it'll be in the direction so let me be
and this is our field of vision if this
is our field of vision six months later
now the Sun is setting now the Sun is
setting all the way to the right on the
right horizon and if we look straight up
this star now this star now is going to
be to the right is going to be to the
right of straight up so what just
happened here well it looks like
relative to straight up and where we're
looking at the exact kind of position of
the earth looking we're looking in the
same straight we're making sure that
we're picking times of years and times a
day we're straight up is is the same
direction we're looking in the same
direction of the universe
it looks like the position of that star
has actually shifted and if this was
let's say that this is let's say this is
the middle of summer and that this is
the middle of winter doesn't have to be
it could be any other two points in time
six months apart then when we look at
the this star in the summer it's going
to be over here summer it's going to be
right over there when we look at the
star in the winter it is going to be
over here and in general for any star
especially stars that are in the same
plane as the solar system you can find
two points in the year where that star
is that I'm kind of a maximum distance
from center and those are the two
distances those are the two times of
year that you'll want to care the most
about because it'll be most interesting
to measure this angle and I want to be
clear this angle here is going to be the
same thing it's going to be the same
thing as this angle there you can see
it's symmetric this way I mean this is a
whatever this angle is going to be and
you could look at this this is kind of a
this is an equilateral triangle now
sorry this is this is an isosceles
triangle whatever whatever this distance
is from here to here is going to be the
same as this distance from here to here
and so this angle is going to be equal
to that angle and that angles
to be equal to that angle what I want to
do in the next video is think about if
we're able to precisely measure these
angles either one of them or both of
them and let me be clear if this angle
in the night sky is Theta and this angle
right here is Theta the difference over
here is two theta so one option if you
want to kind of make sure that your
numbers reasonably good you can measure
just the total difference that it is
around the center and then divide by two
but in the next video what I do is if
you are able to measure the change in a
parent or the apparent change in angle
here if you were to if you were to be
able to measure that how would you be
able to use that information to actually
figure out the distance to this star